en resumen ha pasado que estos jóvenes
han tenido que renovar cada dos años
este permiso este permiso para poder
tener una licencia de conducción para
poder tener un permiso de trabajo que
les permita vivir en este país de forma
legal que les permita también tener
seguridad social pero lo tiene que hacer
cada dos años y no ha habido estabilidad
a pesar de que por la administración y
por la casa blanca han pasado gobiernos
demócratas y republicanos y precisamente
el cual cumplirse esta década en las
principales ciudades del país pues hay
protestas de estos jóvenes soñadores que
piden exactamente eso estabilidad yo
bailé les había prometido en campaña es
su estabilidad un camino a la
legalización definitiva para ellos poder
no tener que seguir renovando cada dos
años este permiso de trabajo está esta
posibilidad de vivir en este país
legalmente a pesar de haber llegado acá
desde niños y a pesar de estar pagando
sus impuestos acorde mente es resaltar
que el 6 de julio habrá una audiencia
clave para definir
este programa de acción definida
definida para los jóvenes esposos
cristóbal cambiamos de tema y otra
noticia que llega de eeuu la reserva
federal tomó una nueva medida para
controlar la alta inflación en el país
verdad contános de qué se trata
si es el alza de intereses de las tasas
de interés de referencia de la reserva
federal del banco central de eeuu que
monet que maneja la política monetaria
sube estas tasas de interés un
0.75 por ciento esto es el alza el alza
más grande en la reserva federal desde
1994 y lo hace precisamente para
responder a la alta inflación que tiene
el país hace unos días apenas se conoció
la tasa de inflación del 8 6% acumulada
al mes de mayo esta es la tasa de
inflación más grande en eeuu desde
1981 y esto obviamente ha hecho que los
precios no solamente del arriendo sino
de los productos básicos estén trepados
y aumente obviamente la dificultad para
acceder a estos bienes la reserva
federal también el dijo que para finales
del 2022 espera subir aún más las tasas
de interés dice que podrían llegar las
tasas de interés al 34 por ciento así
entonces actualmente las tasas de
interés de referencia del banco central
de eeuu de la red hoy está entre el 15 %
y
1,75 por ciento